car si on refaisait une vidéo des mines
mais cette fois avec des gens très
mature on va changer quelque est alors
vraiment la meilleure on va faire la
d'ordinaire mousse
j'ai joué à ce jeu une seconde ma vie
donc je suis très nul
bah je me poserai toutes sont inscrits
dans quel point on le connaît toutes ses
actes par coeur je te perds un peu je
trouve tout appel 5-0 forme sans
séquelle origine ce prénom italien a
battu par les alliés non portugais
français lorsque l'espagnol je connais
pas trop mais je ne peux pas signer ou
pas à quoi t'as pas voir l'addition s'il
vous plaît mais il en est pour faire une
vidéo pop ouais ils sont bien ces sons
diakite ans dans l'isère bien qu'il est
bourré quand une boisson alcool n'a
jamais goûté un petit verre a débouté
mais moi je préfère le vin blanc ouais à
l'esa charles est parti on prend le
petit pont je joue le mec avec une
cornemuse était morte a perdu merci
sacha pas jouer avec nous ça n'a pas
duré longtemps mais c'est vraiment un
pote on est toujours avec noah aller son
frère j'ai vraiment le même visage
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie à
vingt ans alors si vous avez compris
envoyé compris aux ligues libye tant
qu'un classe ulis si t'as pas en quoi
l'école
miou tous les livres on ait shalom je
suis collégienne tu veux faire ça toute
la ville tout arrêter si je peux passer
à autre chose à un moment se faire plus
tard technicienne du registre on a prévu
ton destin
d'ailleurs c'est ce à quoi on est
maintenant avec balthazar jeu dans ce
présent donc tu vas devoir choisir un
autre style un peu nous le décrire un
peu ou pas alors il la décroche ai je
pas prendre lui comment il s'appelle
julien michel hockey michel un bon élève
cancre dans ce quota moyenne est de
taille 9 au dogmatisme mais qui arrive
en 6ème d'affaires auquel enough
je suis chaud si si tu avais une
baguette magique magic fans amoureuses
oui mais bon ça reste entre nous et
personne ne sait encore cette année en
mai et la martinique est un homme qui
aime les femmes de couleur ne suis pas
comme marine le pen
si tu voulais me donner un petit conseil
dans la vie n'importe quoi c'est quoi
pense que tu devrais plus de 100
destructions les jeux je trouve que tu
fais plus des trucs sur genre l'alcool
tout ça tu connais bien que tu es bien
gras blanc jeans et toi tu avais
pouvoirs magiques vous allez porter
téléporter donc te fais chier avec moi
oui exact toi si tu avais dix mille
euros
tu fais quoi moi et j'aurais encore plus
d'argent je travaille beaucoup poussent
donc tu travailler plus pour gagner plus
c'est quoi le dire des trucs que tu as
volé un chéquier vous rien que l'on
apprécié fini tu m'en parlent comme si
c'était un pote à moi quoi y'a pas de
soucis d'accord pas m moi je suis le
pilote du véhicule et qui tirent sur les
ennemis à l'aide de tours petits deezer
c'est quoi ton youtuber préféré a choisi
on oublie ce que tu viens de dire ta vie
de fille a du travail
je travaillais chien hip hop travail pop
tu vas nous faire un petit pas de spi oh
je trouve que l'école c'est bien ou
c'est la pire activités du monde
taklha certains cas avec la prof et tout
s'est mieux profs mais les gens qui
s'est un peu plus vertueux comme bon au
sommet ni aux symboles nuages qui veut
dire qu'il faut être un véhicule aérien
qu'est ce qu'on peut considérer comme un
véhicule aérien crois que ce must
aquatique ou aérien très franchement
avec une tête de sous marins je pensais
plutôt pratique pour une meuf qui fait
de la biologie je suis un peu déçu eh
bien on est vraiment j ai tout fait des
blagues en beauté la fin il fermement
je ne sais pas pourquoi ça sert manière
et c'est michel qui vole alors c'est pas
du tout mon bac quoi ça c'est une
information
oui nous donne une information sur les
animaux je trouve que je jouais
extrêmement fort et personnel
un véhicule terrestre moi j'ai du pack
véhicule ou pas avoir un véhicule pour 2
ya quelqu'un qui tirait quelqu'un qui
ont conduit occupent des attaquants
soient architectes ou combattants ou
combattants on attend une charge et
extender non ça n'existe pas c'est un
battant et le truc que tu aimes bien
chez les 9 centres
si jamais les blancs secs et de la barbe
est bien sympa comme tout d'abord toi tu
es en bas âge contrôle
on remarquera que je suis quand même
très très bon tireur contre 1 mondial
devait voter pour quelqu'un n'importe
qui sur tel tuer votre est parti
maintenant moi avec ce que du frais
s'étaient déplacés lors par exemple des
vielles bâtisses aux tours de la fin si
l'ambiance a attaqué par les terroristes
faudra beaucoup de rigueur ou de pierres
peu après ça c'est un vrai débat
d'architecte ou petits bâtons ou rom ou
insulte préféré vraiment que ça fait du
bien quand on peut la sortir s'il vous
plaît lorsque tu préfères c'est vraiment
mon maire pas de fonds pour faire
réveiller le dragon des langues il
passait par là je suppose mais va
falloir combattre les centristes qui
vole un voile à megan guy combes encore
des ennemis à combattre il faut cacher
les tuer parce que la paye des renforts
l'effort au poste-clé de ce morceau
attend le monde s'attend marceau cet
enfant n'a pris aucune drogue un châle
précise elle doit pouvoir que tellement
la barre s'est téléporté oui on va le
faire 3 2 1
ouais c'était plutôt républicain
socialiste tout est cool ou écolo
lorsque j'ai à l'école si tu vas à
l'école tu es écolo ah ouais tu as tu
penses pas de françois hollande
croyez-nous l'été os qui envoient des
restos pour tuer n'ayant qu'à quatre
mois elle ira qui devrait envoyer des
gens pour envoyer la paye là bas on se
trémousse que tu viens de dire est bien
dit lui à françois hollande qui nous
regardent
faut arrêter de faire la guerre dr oui
spectacle sur scène actuellement à paris
au palace je sais pas pourquoi je saute
c'est un délire allez au revoir
moi j'ai déjà fait 10 milliards de
soirées alcoolisées mais j'ai jamais vu
un mec faire ça beaucoup ne savent plus
ce qu'ils font certains se mettent en
danger
lui c'est pas juste un mec bourré c'est
un mec bourré serial killer